[Music]
Jimmy chin and his wife tried about sir
Haley and approached me about doing a
film project like a documentary film
like a feature and which is a big
opportunity for me as a professional
climber and I was like Oh that'd be
great like that's cool but the only
thing that I cared about filming on or
making a movie about was all cab and in
a way I was like it's kind of a amazing
opportunity to do justice to all cab
right you know because if any climb in
the whole world deserves a movie about
it it's El Cap I mean it's the most
beautiful wall in the world it's like
that is a pinnacle climbing achievement
that you know should be documented in a
in a good way if it's if it's ever gonna
be filmed it should be done right right
now and so I kind of took it as a cool
opportunity to you know combine my
long-term dream with this big you know
professional opportunity and and in some
ways it was good to have a little bit of
it's not added pressure because I mean
they didn't care about what icon they
just wanted to make a film with me and I
was the one that was like we're dealing
out on El Cap because that's what I want
to do and they're like sweet yes
obviously that's a you know very very
photogenic wall but um but it was a
little bit good for me to have a little
extra you know move to actually go and
start working on it because you know
without having ever talked to anyone
about it for years I just kind of sat on
it it's like oh it's too big it's too
big I don't know and then once I started
talking my friends about it and it
became like a film project and and then
once it was once we were filming then I
started talking to my friends more about
it and and then it became more real to
me it works on this is happening yeah
yeah yeah and then I started the real
process of like okay I'm working on it
this is what I'm doing and then I did it
uh-huh and and you have this you have a
very hangdog loose like kind of response
to all this like as I recall like when
you get to the top you're like you know
dude it's cool all right you know what's
next oh no no of everything I've come
into my life getting to the top of El
Cap I was hoping for even I mean even
right now I'm still like pretty psyched
I mean it's pretty amazing but you got I
mean you have this nickname right like
no big deal like Alex no big deal I
didn't come on right right I'm sure you
didn't you know um no but El Cap was
very meaningful to me for sure I think
it's probably the first thing I've done
in climbing that I'm
really proud of so what is the what is
the physical training look like for you
beyond just the climbing itself like do
you what other kind of prep do you do
I mean basically climbing and climbing
specific training which is a like
fingerboarding like hanging from small
edges and systematic ways different grid
dyes that your fingers and then
opposition stuff you know so like
working your pushing muscles instead of
your pulling muscles just to keep from
getting injured mhm and then I was
actually doing a fair amount of
stretching before I'll cap just because
one of the key one of the hardest parts
on the crux is this big karate kick to
the left with you know it's just this
crazy maneuver where you have to put
your foot like way over there and so as
I got more flexible that that became
more secure mmhmm yeah it but lots
finger pull-ups yeah all that kind of
stuff yeah but um I mean for the six
months I guess preceding the actual real
so maybe the five months preceding the
real solo I was I was as I call it all
in the program you know so I was I was
getting like a weekly massage to help
with recovery my diet was was like
pretty locked and I basically didn't eat
any sugar or anything
I had no supplemental dessert stuff for
you know five months I was basically
eating vegan diet but with egg still mmm
but um but very clean very wholesome
like not eating out that much just like
you know eating rice and vegetable type
meals and just like I was probably the
leanest I've ever been but part of that
because I was doing a lot of exercise so
I was also just burning a lot mm-hmm
but I think when I when I when I sent
the free router when would I actually
free so it all ki was probably three or
four pounds lighter than I normally am
but part of us just from all the hiking
and stuff too but yeah yeah yeah I don't
know if I was very fit you know
um actually I was I just said I was in
New York for us couple days I was
climbing with him in the cameraman one
of the very tape filmmaker guys that was
shooting with me for the actual ascent
and so he was the guy that walked to the
base with me and then was also on the
summit basically he felled me taking off
the bottom and then he ran around and
made it to the top and then he was on
top when I got there uh-huh
he's pretty cool but um it's got Claire
and so I was coming in the gym with him
because he's a rock climber also and uh
he was like oh when we saw you in the
spring like yeah we all were all like
whoa he looks fit
you know he's been training which I mean
I'm always climbing and always training
to some extent but it was for me a
different level like a level of focus
and specificity for that particular well
and I think because I cared about the
objective so much more I was willing to
really you know people were you know
offering you cookies or something you're
like no I don't need that you know like
I've got a goal and so what does it all
mean to you like you it's it's been a
moment you know since that occurred like
with a little time and perspective like
you know how do you think about it and
like what is the significance of that
for you I don't know I mean I think I
might need another moment you know yeah
it's funny because I'm still talking
about a lot in the film project is still
ongoing and I've been doing a lot of
talks around El Cap and so it still
feels pretty fresh for me even though
it's been six seven months now but um I
don't know I added a couple of chapters
to my book so there'll be a revised
edition of my book coming out right and
so I've been writing a lot about editing
you know it's like I'm still very much
in the world the free writer yeah and so
I don't know I mean but it's it's
definitely the biggest goal or project
I've ever had in climbing yeah it's
definitely well I think it holds
significance for the sport in general I
mean it certainly raises awareness about
what you guys do and and and you know I
think it allows people to have a level
of appreciation that there may be you
know they don't have because it's kind
of a it's this weird mysterious
subculture I mean any non climber can
definitely walk into you so many valley
and look at the walls and and just think
oh my goodness right that is outrageous
I mean I kind of feel the same way about
I I mean I was backing you somebody in
the fall and I look up at El Cap and
honestly it doesn't you know even having
having climbed without a rope now it
still looks so crazy like yeah what an
amazing law Mike that's so cool I mean
do you think like you know when I was 15
or whatever like do you think back to
that young kid and and think what would
he think of what yeah I mean ooh yeah 10
or 15 years ago the first times I looked
at El Cap I thought it looked totally
crazy and now I mean it looks a little
bit less so but you still look at it
you're like that's an intimidating wall
I grad is a big crazy wall yeah like
yeah I mean you see people up there and
is like little tiny dots and you're just
like wow that's really big right
yeah I mean what is what is what do you
think is like behind it like what's
driving you what is the what's the
motivation is it is it love is it up is
it a sense of adventure is it a
competitiveness like what's the ecology
behind what motivates you to do all this
I don't know I mean it's a lot of things
I guess I mean part of it is definitely
trying to see what I can do what I'm
capable of I mean especially with El Cap
is it was something that I felt like I
was maybe uniquely capable of doing in
in this generation at least I mean I'm
sure people will do it in the future
more and you know might not be that
crazy in 20 years but um but at this
point in time I was like if anyone is
gonna do this I think it could be me if
if I apply myself to and if I really
care about it and you know being the
first to do something like that I mean
was that that hasn't always been a huge
motivator for me for various projects
but for El Cap I mean I did kind of I
did kind of want that right I was like I
mean you look at that wall and you're
just like I'm so proud yeah I know
and I'd spent all my years of climbing
looking at it is the ultimate objective
like the pinnacle of rock climbing and I
was like that could you know I could I
could do that that could be me and so
then you know I sort of felt obligated
to try it's an extraordinary
accomplishment this movie and it's a
very delicate tightrope walk because the
simple fact that you're present around
him inevitably influences him and that's
something you explore in the movie and
trying to remain adequately removed so
he has the space to do what he does and
in the way that he aspires to do it
while also trying to you know
responsibly documented so you can tell
the story I mean it's it's like a big
skew you know to try to solve that yeah
and I love how you kind of break the
fourth wall with that I mean you bring
the filmmaker in the filmmaking process
into the actual narrative of the movie
and that really elevates the the
compelling nature of the story that
you're trying to tell it's like that
physics thing like the simple
observation of of a subatomic particle
is going to
you know change its position in nature
right and that's a micro example of what
you are experiencing just trying to be
there and I don't want to you know spoil
it for people that haven't seen it but
that gets played out you know in a
pretty interesting way ya know I think
you can have it I mean it it's a lot
also about respect for the craft and the
athlete and you know I mean you you as
an athlete I mean you know that you
don't want to like take away from the
whole inspiration of the film you know
by being there and filming him it's
always been a conundrum in my field of
war you know because especially in
climbing and probably in you know
surfing and there's this whole idea of
purity right of of why you do it
but it was interesting because that
decision to include the filmmakers you
know it was a hard one and it it was one
of those things that we had to see if we
could make it work and in a true way on
different levels right and without it
yes yeah and without it right you did
you did a cut without that it was always
about degree but the filmmakers right
how much do we put in like and also what
is it really about you know so it's it's
not about the people are interested in
how we did it right like that would be
like the clear one reason why you
include them because people want to see
these guys hanging on ropes and they're
like how did they do this how did they
do this it was often a really big
question of merit wherever like they're
like so what the fourth person was
filming it you're like no where they
were filming themselves yeah but what's
relevant about breaking that fourth wall
and bringing the filmmakers into it is
this question of purity like what does
it mean to do this from you know a pure
place of the heart and and you're Jimmy
you're like struggling with that because
you have these conflicting drives right
to respect what Alex is trying to do and
all
so to have some fidelity to the creative
process of telling an amazing story that
will inspire millions of people and the
ethical questions of what is right yeah
telling him causes right a guy yeah what
does that mean and you're shouldering
this incredible ethical conundrum this
burden of being respond not responsible
necessarily but a participant in
something that could be fatal and that
seemed essential to include yeah because
it also gets to the existential heart of
the movie itself right because in
dealing with that ethical question about
how what is our responsibility in this
situation you have to stop and think
about all the worst-case scenarios and
then think about the reasons why you
would make a film like this like what is
it is it justifiable like is that
worthwhile and you know it gets to then
that idea of Alex living a life of
intention and every day is exactly what
he's wanted what he wants to do he's
thought deeply about his own mortality
and his own death and he chooses to do
this and you know and for us that that
that idea like a life of intention makes
it worthwhile right
clearly we thought he would not get hurt
we trusted him deeply we had trusted him
to make the right decisions and not to
climb you know like you see in the film
like that's not to climb but it was you
know including the crew was a way to get
there to talk about this I mean also you
know what is has always been a solo
endeavor for Alex like he's in a van he
gets up and he goes and does this and no
one knows about it
maybe someone later you know reports it
on a climbing vlog his greatest free
solo of his life ended up being about a
connection rather than being isolated
you know he had his best friends next to
him for a year and a half
training alongside him giving him
feedback trying to refine their shots
while he's are finding his moves yeah um
and all saying like we're never gonna
ask you whether or not you're gonna
actually climb and we like you for who
you are
you know you're you and we're still here
yeah and then here this woman who
entered his life who for I think for
probably the first time in his life said
I'm gonna tell you how I feel about this
but I still love you yeah you know and
I'm not going I'm gonna try not to go
anywhere so I think that it was this
weird process for Alex that it became
about connecting with people and
communing with people sharing an
experience whereas it always had been
just this alone like loner endeavor for
him and the crew was a way of bringing
that to life by showing the crews
feelings about this and how they
interact with Alex was our way of trying
to get to that truth now to go into that
just briefly one of the reasons I think
that glyphosate was not put on the
market in 1958 when it was discovered is
because the Japanese inventor of that
chemical recognized that that was a
water-soluble type toxin you do not want
to introduce a water-soluble stalks and
into the environment because you can
never get it back right in that where if
you have a fat-soluble stalks and it'll
actually be sequestered by mycelium in
the soil if it gets into a human or
another Manimal
it'll be sequestered by fat cells so it
never hits the brain it'll be protective
a water-soluble stalks and on the other
hand can't be subtracted out of the
ecosystem because everything on planet
earth including your human body is water
and so that means that sorry to
interrupt but that means that this
chemical can pass through that one cell
you know that one cell of the the gut
lining and the the brain blood barrier
as well right it's going everywhere and
it's also before you even gets the human
body going everywhere and so the current
statistics is that less than 1/10 of 1%
of the roundup used on the planet
actually hits a weed the other 99.99%
gets into the soil and in the water
system and washes off and so we are now
seeing the runoff from these farms and
in the water table itself so we have
fossil aquifers in the United States
here that run from Canada all right all
the way down to historically Mexico that
is now dried up we've we've turned over
a thousand square miles of
a Texas into desert over the last 20
years from sucking water out of the
ground that fossil aquifer is now
contaminated with roundup that's
filtered down into this ancient
freshwater source for us and then in the
same moment you've got the Mississippi
River which collects over 80 percent of
all the roundup in the country and then
it's evaporating the whole time so it's
going into the air that you breathe and
then it goes into the clouds and then it
rains down on us
recent studies in the air and rainfall
in the southern United States is showing
75 percent of rain 75 percent of air
containment and it was roundup so before
you even take a bite of who's you're
being hit with an antibiotic when you
breathe you're getting hit with an
antibiotic when you when you experience
rainfall and so you may be growing
organic crops but they're getting rained
on and so we have now locked this
water-soluble toxin into our environment
fortunately you know to give you a
little bit of breather here from the bad
news is that there are bacteria and
fungi that can eventually digest the
glyphosate the downside is we need to
stop spraying it so they can return
we're decimating those very bacteria and
fungi by the presence of roundup to the
point where they're not digesting it
current estimates is if we stop spraying
roundup tomorrow it would take about 50
years before ecosystem saw a drop and
level around up below our toxic levels
and what what is the current you know
market cap isn't the right word but like
how Pro whew like huh
like it's billions of dollars right is
there is there anybody outside of the
organic farming community that does not
use roundup or people that are even just
weeding their own gardens at home and
spraying their lawns actually we're
started so before we genetically
modified crops to be able to be sprayed
directly with roundup in 1996 that that
occurred but before that it was really
the homeowner that was contributing most
to our talks and Load because in the
1980s the EPA allowed Monsanto to go
direct to consumer with their
advertising for this chemical and so
they created those Super Bowl
commercials of a guy walking out of his
suburban garage with a dramatic
soundtrack and he had to pistol grips on
his side and he came out and and boldly
sprayed down the four dandelions that
were drunk in his dry
which happened to be super food that
kill cancer but anyway he sprays these
four dandelion kills the tooth kills the
only medicine on his property and you
know so suddenly it was it was by far
and away the most effective direct
consumer advertising ever and ever
because suddenly males in the United
States realized it could be manly to
weed right they're like shooting guns
they're shooting guns there it's easy
warfare you know whatever it is instead
of having to actually bend over and put
on a pair of gloves or whatever it is
and so we started broadcasting this
stuff across driveways sidewalks patios
into our you know garden spaces and
everything else and now the difference
between a homeowner who is going to go
through a couple gallons and a farmer
who will go through tens of thousands
gallons the farmers super careful with
the usage because their margins are so
low mm-hmm
the phone the home owner doesn't care so
they're spraying it down and they might
use a quarter of a gallon of glyphosate
in an afternoon whereas a whole farm
might treat the entire thousand acres
with that same quarter gallon so the the
the smaller the user in some ways the
more dumping of this chemical date when
they were doing so by the 1980s we were
drinking roundup out of our municipal
water systems and getting into our water
system that's unbelievable well let's
take a moment and and and just kind of
you know canvas what the discussion is
around glyphosate because I think you
know it's worth mentioning that as soon
as you bring this up we start to venture
tiptoe into this world of like you know
crazy conspiracy theories and you must
be you know some some you know insane
hippie person to be bringing this up and
you know don't don't mind him like he's
just a wacko he's a whack job as a
marginal character you know we know this
stuff is safe it's been around forever
it's been vetted you know the EPA
they're on it they know what's you know
they know what's healthy for us if it
was dangerous they would have outlawed
it and this has been around for a long
time and there's no indication that
anybody's getting sick from this so what
are you talking about yeah if the
conspiracy theorist was right then we'd
see one and two people with cancer we'd
see one in 30 kids with autism we'd see
Parkinson's going crazy yeah they're
literally repeating back if if if it was
toxic we would see literally what we're
seeing and so the reality is the public
health statistics have gotten so grim in
the last eight years that nobody can
call this a conspiracy theory anymore
but it's almost like yeah but that's
where's the direct where's the smoking
gun a smoking gun is what's been missing
that's what we found in 2012 so in 2012
we found it backwards I don't think
anybody's actually smart enough with the
human gray matter that were given to
actually create a paradigm shift
prospectively right so every great you
know mind that we look to in past
Galileo or you know Ben Franklin or
anybody we said ho they discovered
something or you know Edison these just
came at moments when the evidence got so
overwhelming that it would became
obvious right and so in the same way in
2012 the evidence was getting so
overwhelming that we were onto something
in the nutrition world but we at the
time I was still thinking cancer a
cancer therapy because my background was
in chemotherapy development and so when
I found these molecules in soil that
looked similar to the chemotherapy I'd
been making a lot of bells started
ringing of like what is that where'd it
come from how is there medicine in the
dirt like where is that coming from and
within a few weeks of that discovery of
those molecules we found out that
bacteria and fungi were making these
specific shapes of these carbon
molecules and that really closed the
loop for me because there had been some
papers coming out in the mid 2000s in
the cancer world that we're starting to
say that the bacteria in your gut were
predicting which cancers you would get
if you're missing these bacteria you
would get prostate cancer if you have
these bacteria you would get breast
cancer that was so radically bizarre and
out there for our current model even to
this day as to how cancer worked but now
you fast forward 810 years and now
there's tens of thousands of articles
that are showing that genomically the
bacterial genome is way more important
in determining cancer than the human
genome and and so this reality was
hitting in so in 2012 when we discovered
these chemicals that look a little like
chemotherapy that are made by bacteria
and fungi in the soil it suddenly closed
the loop of oh my gosh what if the
bacteria in our gut is doing the same
thing what if the bacteria and the fungi
are actually our best source of medicine
for everything
and so that's the direction we were
going but as soon as we put this into
petri dishes with cancer cells and
beyond we suddenly realize none another
there's something way deeper happening
with these this information stream
coming out of bacteria and fungi and it
was my chief science officer dr. John
Gill day is a PhD in genetics and cell
biology and he was the first to realize
that we had put our finger on the
glyphosate toxicity issue as that this
communication network from the bacteria
and fungi was actually supporting the
protein structure in our gut lining and
so it turns out that the gut is held
together these trillions of cells that
make up that cellophane layer by tight
junctions these are velcro like proteins
that hold one microscopic cell to the
next to create this coherent carpet of
two tennis courts and he had recognized
before this in a number of other labs
that started to publish that glyphosate
seemed to increase the permeability of
this membrane and nobody was really sure
why yet but we suddenly realized that if
this bacterial communication network was
in there we we couldn't injure the in
the membrane we it became bulletproof to
the glyphosate injury and so in that
journey we started a really study
glyphosate in its relationship to the
human cells because like you said
Monsanto has been swearing up and down
that there is no harm to the human body
because the sugar may pathway only
exists in bacteria and fungi well that
may be true regarding that enzyme target
but the classic thing with any drug is
it always has off target effects all
right and so that's why drugs have side
effects is they don't actually go and do
exactly what your doctor says it's going
to go do it's going to hit a bunch of
the receptors and do other things the
side effects of glyphosate that are
outside of this Shikha main pathway is
direct injury to the protein structure
that holds your gut lining together this
would be bad news if that was it but it
turns out that every macro membrane in
your body the blood vessels that that
fuel your entire body with oxygen and
nutrients are held together with the
same tight junctions the blood-brain
barrier that perfekt protects your
peripheral nervous system in your brain
same tight junctions the kidney tubules
that are held together to detox your
body same tight junctions and so what's
happened as we've introduced a chemical
that's directly toxic to this this
velcro-like protein
as we turn into leaky sibs on the
front-end gut leak and nasal sinus leak
and so every time we breathe every time
we eat we're starting to leak in our
immune system gets overwhelmed and then
the blood vessels that are supposed to
deliver either an immune response from
peripheral or get nutrients to some
distant space is also leaking and so
we're getting permeability of the blood
vessels then you get to the blood-brain
barrier this is supposed to be the Holy
of Holies a peripheral nerve or the
brain is supposed to be protected
against everything in your blood because
even glucose which is the main fuel for
your brain should not get into the brain
in an unregulated fashion it will damage
the nerves and so Holy of Holies of the
central and peripheral nervous system is
being destroyed and so if that's true if
glyphosate was really damaging that then
we should see a massive explosion in
neurologic injury to children and adults
starting in about 1996 and that's
exactly when we see this steep increase
happening in autism Alzheimer's
Parkinson's neurodegenerative conditions
like MS autoimmune diseases and all the
rest we were doing a counterterrorism
exercise the the goal was to test this
new equipment that the R&D department at
the military had created it was unmanned
video and sonar designed to detect
attack swimmers and attack divers coming
in to put bombs on our ships and
equipment so they set it up on the PR in
Sydney Harbor along them alongside the
Navy base and it's it's very central to
everything you can see the Harbour
Bridge it's not that far away the Opera
House that everyone knows about you can
see all that and just out there last
year and I took one of those ferries so
I was visualizing it perfectly yeah so
when you're moving away from the Sydney
Opera House and that's behind you on
your right-hand side yeah and you get to
that fort in the middle of the harbor
for tennis exactly so if you look 45
degree angle over to the Navy base right
by the pier right there is where I got
attained no one has been attacked in
Sydney Harbor in 60 years at that point
no no that was it that was kind of a
banner year though overall for shark
attack were like 21 that year I think
I was a it was a little less than that
but there was a guide the day after me
at Bondi which is you know as the crow
flies probably five miles away and he
lost his hand as well so I've got the
new guy in the water he's pretending to
be an attack swimmer all the Rd guys and
my chief are up on the bow of one of the
warships watching and this equipments on
the pier trying to detect him and he's
swimming around for about half an hour
and I thought I'd do him a good turn and
I said jump out mate I'll take over for
you you know I rolled over the edge of
the little black zodiac in a black
wetsuit and a pair of fins and I was
doing what we call finning I was on my
back on the surface just kicking my legs
and it was a 3-tier thing we were gonna
do surf or swimming to see if it could
detect us we're gonna do scuba to see if
it could detect us and then pure oxygen
rebreathers with no bubbles to see if we
could detect that so we're still in the
first phase you know this is 40 minutes
into testing and the form the very first
day and I'm in the water on the surface
unless it's like this is simple routine
yeah this is nothing this is like the
boringest day ever and I to get up at 4
o'clock in the morning for this [ __ ] so
it's end of February February 11th so
the start of February which is the end
of summer for us it's probably the
hottest season of the year but it was
kind of chilly it was overcast the
waters murky in Sydney Harbour so
combining all of that you can't see
through the water at all and I'm one of
my first runs towards one of the
warships that I'm you know pretending to
attack and I look over my left shoulder
to make sure that I'm going in the right
direction and before I can turn back I
just get this massive whack in my leg
like someone's hit me with a baseball
bat
and it didn't really hurt it was just
surprising more than anything else and I
turned around to see what it was
thinking the guys in the boat maybe got
too close I couldn't hear cuz I had
water in my ears and I turn around and
my brain couldn't comprehend what I was
seeing because I'd never seen a shark's
head up close in real life like that
before and it took me a few seconds and
I thought [ __ ]
the [ __ ] shark and all these things
ran through my head and I thought okay
okay okay I've seen I've seen the
Crocodile Hunter I've seen Discovery
Channel I'll jab it in the eyeball right
and so I tried hunch it in the face
right yeah that people have said it
works
I just thought eyeball because that's
the softest spot so I tried but I
couldn't move my arm for some reason and
I looked down and I could see all the
teeth half embedded into my thigh I
could see the lips pulled back all the
pink gums and the teeth going all the
way up my leg over my wrist which was by
my side so it had my hand in its mouth
which is why I couldn't move it and it's
still at this point it didn't hurt I
could see the teeth embedded in my hand
ala I just thought okay left hand so I
reached for the eyeball but it had me by
the back of the leg and I I was inches
away from that eyeball just desperately
trying to get my finger in it but I
couldn't reach so I tried to grab it by
the nose and push it off sort of lever
it off that way but all that did was
push the teeth of the lower jaw deeper
into my hamstring so I stopped that and
I cocked back to give it a whack in the
nose and just as I was coming in it
started to shake me and this
all-encompassing pain rattled me to my
core and all the strength went out of my
punch and I yelled and I think that's
when the guys in the safety boat saw
what was going on and when it's shaking
you the lower jaw detaches right and it
goes side to sides and it comes like
this sawing effect yeah it's it's
movable so that yeah it just basically
was sawing the flesh out of my body
while I'm in agony terrified drowning
this is my worst nightmare I was
terrified of sharks really the only two
things I was scared of with sharks and
public speaking so and now this is your
life I know it's we just [ __ ] that's
the way the universe works it out man
yeah you know you'll your greatest fears
can actually become your greatest
strengths and I think if that's really
the theme of your of your whole story
yeah you know you gotta embrace that
[ __ ] mmm-hmm because you don't know you
don't you're not fully aware
of what you can accomplish if you're
letting especially if you're letting
fear hold you back mm-hmm and to be
confronted with that in the most vicious
life-threatening way possible I mean
it's just it's it's beyond imagination
you know and and I've seen that there's
photographs online you can see the
pictures of your arm yeah the actual
attack video is on YouTube yeah yeah it
looks like that I watch that and it's
sort of like a Loch Ness monster thing
it's all like raining you're like what's
actually going you can't really tell
what's going on but those still
photographs of your of your arm and in
the back of your leg are just yeah and
then I know when you got appetite you
tight you say like you show these
pictures and some of that and like 50
guys like passed out yeah 50 I really
use 53 people of pasta 51 men only two
women men yeah I mean it's as gruesome
as it comes that image of your arm is I
almost wish I didn't see it I think I've
had any pass out in America though I'm
heading up to Atlanta to talk to IBM on
Sunday so I'm wondering if I'm gonna get
my first American casualty yeah I'm a
little bit worried though because you
guys like to sue people the warning I do
I give the warning I make very light
hearted of it we have a good time but
some people just tell him to turn away I
do one of the guys said he wasn't even
watching he said he just listened to me
speaking any pass to me that guy needs
to hear your message a little bit more
than yeah but it's a lot of fun
not that day though that was not fun at
all so so there you are
these guys are hauling you out you know
it's interesting that that like
fight-or-flight response typically you
hear that the pain comes later you know
because the adrenaline is so you know on
on overdrive in the situation but you
are already feeling the pain yeah the
the the amount of blood that you were
losing I mean I it's it's shocking that
you're alive like it's totally credible
that you didn't just bleed out yeah but
it's testament to what the human body is
capable of when I was super
well guys you know exactly those guys
ever yeah like you know deal with the
situation and to be you know calm under
fire yeah well one of the guys hadn't
even slept that night he was actually
hungover as hell passed out in the
bottom of the boat you imagine waking up
to your buddy being eaten by a shark and
having to do first aid the heart of the
guys literally reached his hand in and
like pinched an artery right yeah
because they couldn't stop the bleeding
they put a torn account on using the
strap from a lifejacket because we
didn't have any medical equipment we
didn't think it was gonna be a day like
that at all because this is where we
work every day so one of the guys the
new guy who I'd pulled out of the water
earlier I had to stick his hand inside
my leg and pinch closed an artery
otherwise I would have died and it
should have been that guy right you were
like we're swapping out for him well
everyone was saying that if it was him
there's no way he would have lived he
was much smaller than me that the shark
would have killed him so maybe it was
for a reason
unconsciously maybe well you know I I
didn't when it came back from London I
didn't know anything I didn't know there
was it I didn't know there was a MIT
this is a theme with you tipping over on
the track like I'm doing the ADEs ride
on my mountain bike I didn't I had no
idea there was a vegan movement I had no
idea there was an animal rights movement
I didn't know about you yet I didn't
know I knew absolutely nothing I'm still
to the point where I I'm not sharing
anything because I don't think there's
anyone that cares and the the moment
happened when my husband came home one
day from doing some shopping he'd been
to native foods and he saw a little cute
group of people meeting he it happened
to be Mercy for Animals he got a flyer
and brought it home it was like look
there's like people that talk about what
you talked about and I picked up the
phone and called mercy for animals in
Santa Monica and got a hold of Ari
solemn and I'm like you guys like dick
you like what how do you what are you do
and so he
so come up come up and see us let's have
lunch and that was the beginning of
recognizing that anybody talks about
this and that melisten to them and
actually care and are creating a pretty
large movement of people that give a
crap well it's amazing as somebody who
not so long ago didn't even know existed
that you're having PSAs airing during
the Olympics and you've created this
compassionate Champs movement like tell
me what that's all about so I'm learning
more and more every day but when I
started compassion champs it was a it
was really kind of more out of a desire
to meld together compassion and strength
I felt like there was you know nobody
really that that was having a real
conversation about being able to be
caring and compassionate and and loving
and empathetic but also strong and
fierce and badass and you know those
those two just weren't coming together
as a group of people so that that's
that's where it was kind of born out of
I'm learning more and more as I am
traversing this movement and reading
more research and understanding more
from being a part of the game changers
film which we can talk about I wanna
talk that you know people and and and
just from my own experience sadly and
and really disappointing to me is by and
large people don't care about the
animals they just don't they just they
don't care about the suffering they
don't want to know about it they don't
want to hear they don't want you to show
them they don't definitely not want you
to talk about it and they really don't
want you to talk about it when you're
all eating but people do care about
their health and they do care about
their performance not just athlete you
know athletic performance people just
care about their general performance and
being better in their life right a lot
of the people that you've had on here so
the conversation that I'm having is is
changing a bit more
I think it's I'm almost feeling more
like a undercover animal activist
because it's at the core of what I care
about the most it's the least effective
way to change people's minds right the
way to impact people is is by appealing
to what interests them not what
interests you right such a bummer and I
think that you know the athlete plays a
very interesting role in this movement
because what they're able to do with
their body speaks louder than the words
that come out of many a doctor's mouth
many an activist mouth because when
someone sees you with a silver medal on
sees you on a podium or sees you on that
villager I'm kicking ass it's like wow
how does that how does that person do
that I want to know more about who that
person is and what what inspires them
and what fuels them and telling that
story is a way to impact hearts and
minds that I think is different and
important you know and that's why I
think you know this game changers movie
that you're a part of is gonna be a
really big deal like I haven't seen it
yet I've seen the trailer but I know
it's making a splash you were at
Sundance you just got back from the
Berlin Film Festival tell me what it was
like to you know see that movie be part
of that movie and to participate in in
in screening it before audiences for the
first time yeah it was just a wild
pleasure and honor right I just feel
like you know we're kind of at a tipping
point of this movement you know we're
not anywhere near like a large percent
of the population heating plant base but
I feel like I'm definitely having
outside of the movement right we've to
take ourselves outside to really
recognize but those conversations are at
a much higher level than they used to be
people are at least aware now that
they've decided that that's for them or
not maybe not but screening the film at
at Sundance and at the Berlin Holly in
in in Berlin which was the international
premiere it was
so many different types of people asking
all different types of questions you
know it was that's what I loved about it
it was like a wide variety of of
questions that not just your typical
like oh where are you getting your
protein well they cover that in the film
so maybe that's why they weren't asking
that but and people's reaction to it was
its Sundance it really really caught me
off guard and by surprise normally we're
used to people saying oh okay this is
interesting
plant-based okay I think I might try a
recipe or I might try meatless Mondays
or I'm gonna try this on thus lots of
people we do the Q&A after the film
right there's about 15 of us there the
doctors and the Emeth Lietz I'm the only
female because the other two females
it's a male very much very kind of a bro
heavy totally it's very focused on young
men because they are the ones that are
resistant to change
as far as eating meat and the meat myth
so there's three females in the film and
the other two are still competing so is
the only female there so I just got this
rush of women you know standing in line
to talk about this and every single one
says I'm starting today what do I do for
dinner
somebody else comes up and says I'm
going back to the condo and I'm supposed
to cook for 10 people and I have chicken
in the refrigerator and I can't serve
them that it's you know it's disease
don't you know they would they would she
would pick out different parts of the
movie that she had learned about all of
the gnarliness of chicken and I I can't
in my right mind
serve them that well what if what you
know I don't know what I'm gonna do and
I'm thinking oh my god oh my god
no but cook the chicken let's start
tomorrow you know it's like oh my gosh
it was in a completely different type of
panic all most of these people just just
so moved by what they learned and so
moved by the health aspect that they
were everyone starting tomorrow and so I
was like wow guys we gotta really be
ready for this cuz nobody knew that was
going to be the reaction yeah you better
have your answer
like chambered yeah yeah yeah it was
really exciting I feed them when the
inspiration is is at its peak right
exactly exactly yeah yeah so we yeah
what was that what was the response in
Berlin how is it different
um it was it was gosh I people are a
little bit more subdued there you know I
just said the germs are also questioners
they're much yeah yeah so we got I mean
we yeah we got there's a part in the
film where it kind of goes into tobacco
industry and kind of how they were
eventually exposed even after there was
you know 700 studies that says smoking
kills you but they had you know kind of
kept them all quiet and the PR firm
exponent that is known for hiding big
tobacco hiding a lot of chemicals that
are in different things that we lotions
and things we put on our skin and are
now spinning big agriculture so that was
very that was an interesting topic in
Berlin like a lot of people brought that
what are we gonna do about exponent mmm
that's not okay you know so that that
was a little bit more askance of what
you were trying to go for well yeah but
I mean if you'll see it it kind of it at
least helps people to understand why all
of this how all of this marketing is
working this meat myth is working in the
machine that's behind big agriculture
and the spin that every time something
comes out like what we're doing was
switched for good if we get big enough
which we better and I hope we will
there'll be some type of exponent
whether it's them or someone else doing
a quick spin forward big dairies so that
that is it's it's a pretty integral part
of the film for people to understand why
they're being told this myth like where
it's coming from and and and how much
money is behind that myth so but but but
Germany as a whole and is especially
Berlin I mean Berlin is known as the
vegan capital of Europe so you know it
was really people with a very open minds
to at the film you know
habits are one of the phrases I'd like
to use is that pretty much any of the
results in your life are a lagging
measure of your habits right so you're
right weight is a lagging measure of
your eating habits your bank account is
a lagging measure of your financial
habits your clutter is a lagging measure
of your cleaning habits like the
outcomes are just the the manifestation
of the behaviors that preceded them
right so you kind of get what you repeat
in that way well that makes sense people
understand that that's important so
that's one reason why habits are crucial
but there's another thing that habits do
that is even more central even more
important and that is that your habits
are the way that you embody a particular
identity so every morning that you make
your bed you embody the habits of you
embody the identity of an organized
person someone who's clean every time
you go to the gym you embody the
identity of someone who is fit every
time you sit down to write a sentence or
a page you embody the identity of
someone who's a writer and so in that
sense habits are like every action you
take is kind of like a vote for the type
of person that you believe that you are
and as you take these actions you build
up evidence of a particular identity and
pretty soon your beliefs have something
to like route themselves and it's like
manna you know I showed up at the gym
for four days a week for the last three
months I guess like I'm the type of
person who doesn't miss workouts and
that I think is the true reason what
habits are so important once I realized
how beliefs and behaviors are connected
that there's like this two-way street
then I've started to think all right
maybe this is really something not only
does it deliver those external results
the clean room or the you know bigger
bank account but also the internal
results of shaping your sense of self
image and what you believe right so
let's drill into these four laws you've
got we'll just break them down okay so
I've hinted at this process so far but
the four stages that any habit goes
through Q craving response reward so
there's some type of Q or raw data that
gets your attention
then you predict or interpret that data
in some way which motivates you to act
response and then somehow that behavior
either benefits you or does not benefit
you and that's what gets you to close
the feedback loop and update your
prediction for the next time and decide
if you want to continue that although a
caveat to that I would imagine is that
there is a rule you're saying it either
benefits you or it doesn't but isn't
there an argument that it's it's
benefiting you somehow maybe not in a
good way but you're getting something
out of that like if you have a habit
that's unhealthy
some bad behavior and everybody tells
you you got to stop doing that
you're you're getting some positive
result from that even if it's twisted
you know or unhealthy there's something
inside of you that compels you to act
that way because because you're getting
something out of it right yeah like it
whether it's masking some pain or
whatever it is there there's a reason
behind that all behaviors those that are
repeated service in some way I guess
we'd say all habits serve you in some
way yeah and one way to think about this
is that every behavior produces multiple
outcomes across time so if you take a
bad habit or an unhealthy habit like
eating a doughnut or something the
immediate outcome is favorable but
sugary it's tasty it's enjoyable in the
moment that's how it serves you that's
the reason why you repeated the ultimate
outcome if you repeat that every day for
the next three months or year or
whatever is you end up gaining weight or
you're less healthy or so on for good
habits that's often the reverse right
like sometimes you know the benefit of
going to the gym in many people's eyes
is the immediate outcomes unfavorable
sweat I have to work it's effortful it's
hard and you sacrifice I don't get to
watch TV I got to go there instead you
study me the outcome is unfavorable the
ultimate outcome if you repeat that
habit for two months or a year or
whatever is you're fit and healthy and
this is one of the key challenges of
building good habits and breaking bad
ones is figuring out ways to take the
long-term consequences of your good
habits or of your bad habits and pull
them into the present moment so you feel
a little bit of the pain right now so it
serves you less and to take the
long-term rewards of your good habits
and pull those and
so it feels good this is one reason why
you know it's great to choose like
what's the best form of exercise
well maybe it's about the one that you
enjoy because if it feels good at the
moment now it serves you have a reason
to repeat it so a low carb diet of
course many of them continue to eat a
decent amount of greens in their diet
but they're eliminating all the whites
and and they're hyper vigilant about it
the big difference in the ketogenic diet
are you doing - low carb low protein
which we can talk about and with a
plant-based approach may actually have
some benefit in science or are you doing
a low carb high fat and high protein
diet which probably ages you quicker
than any other diet on the planet and
that isn't always parsed out in their
conversation so the scary skeleton and
the ketogenic diet closet is you'll lose
weight you may have some boost in energy
for a period of time you may be
increasing your mortality risk and they
just don't talk about that with great
regularity so it's a it's a difficult
diet and I think Dave as for trying to
eat in the Google
I don't know that he'd want to be
cornered as a ketogenic diet proponent
he has his brand bulletproof diet but
you know the difficulty he had and my
patients telling me this is you know on
the road it's easier to be plant-based
than it is to eat a strict ketogenic
diet right now of you know a high fat
options you're gonna have to carry
around your own food but the gravest
concern is is it a healthy pattern is
there any natural population and even
slightly approaches it in as done well
long term kind of a bullet shot at the
plant-based movements show me a society
that's been plant-based for centuries
and has thrive that's one of Nina's big
points big points but show me a
community that's you can talk about
Eskimos in the Messiah who live to age
30 or 40 well that's not kind of the
example we're talking about show a
Okinawa type population there was 90%
Plus plant-based and thrive great we
have our example that approximates the
wheat they have great difficulty with
that in fact the scientific data is it's
the converse that they are at risk or
turning their lifespan if it's an
animal-based low-carb diet particularly
if they're emphasizing foods that they
feel are high in
which are typically going to be meats of
a variety of kinds no matter whether
it's grass-fed or not it's the basic
constitution of animal muscle that can
age you excessively in the sciences
well-known so a couple of observations
on that first with respect to the the
degree of difficulty of maintaining a
ketogenic diet it's an interesting thing
to talk about because you're right like
to actually do a ketogenic diet properly
requires an incredible amount of like a
forethought and planning and distance
it's not easy to really dial that in and
make it work compared to a plant-based
diet and yet I feel like the plant-based
diet gets unduly criticized for being
restrictive and too difficult and
something that people are just never
going to be able to maintain long term
despite the fact that both of us have
done that but people are very quick to
jump on the ketogenic bandwagon and try
it with enthusiasm
without that same concern being applied
yeah I agree completely you know just a
couple examples there's uh Joe Rogan had
a surgeon on Shaun Baker and I don't
know Shaun Baker very well we go at each
other a little bit on Twitter and he
said very you know casually even he's an
MD I've done in the ultimate example of
these diets there's a whole group of
people eating nothing but meat three
meals a day literally nothing but meat
and for reasons I don't Kabul used a
carnivore car yeah and he's one of many
I mean he's not the only one that shows
up there they can claim short term some
pretty impressive pictures of their abs
and weight and some of them have some
heart CT data of course there's nothing
published in the literature I want to
come back to that but you know dr. Baker
said well I didn't even bother to check
my labs Joe Rogan said you've been doing
this for a year and goes no I didn't
check my last well I have patients that
do that and they get their labs checked
not under my advice and I have one that
I'm gonna write up maybe on the airplane
flight back to Detroit later this
evening his cholesterol went from two
feet I've never seen it's 250 to 750
during the two months he did a meat only
diet trying to approximate what he was
hearing on these you know
rogue not Rogan kind of podcasts and
it's insanity and it's it's like
religious fervor and follow the leader
without thoughtfulness the only medical
condition that has any data everybody
can verify this pubmed calm kaput in
ketogenic diet refractory epilepsy and
children and some degree adults you have
a number I mean several dozen published
studies on a impact if standard drugs
like dilantin don't work in effect
before dilantin ketogenic diet was a
reasonable choice for kids with epilepsy
as soon as drugs came out it kind of
faded off and has come back for that use
Daniel a man very famous local
psychiatrist and a friend has a grandson
that had refractory seizures rather
sadly and ironically ketogenic diet was
very beneficial you go beyond that
you're justyou're apps and data so
another startup that's hot and it's
we're talking about because your
listeners will hear this is Verta health
VI RTA backed by Stephen Finney MD I
don't know much about him he appeared in
dr. Malhotra's documentary about
visiting the home of Ancel keys one of
the most distorted and misleading
documentaries ever done called the the
pío pío pío PB i don't read it don't
watch it it's a waste time money and
honesty but Verta health claims with a
ketogenic diet that you can reverse your
type 2 diabetes with a high frequency
and they've got a lot of backing and
they've got an app and they've got a you
know a coaching system so they have
published a study in an a journal that
is so obscure and so non reputable but
it is a journal of which there's a
proliferation of scientific journals
that are open and you can either pay to
publish an article or get access but
it's a small study of six months
duration actually the originally ten
weeks duration non-randomized no control
group in the scientific world this is
about as low as it goes and yes with the
dietary plan they advocated very high
dropout rate in the group studied they
showed some drop in measures of diabetic
control towards the better with their
ketogenic diet coaching system and on
that I speak to like brilliant people
and they say well the debate
/ Verta health has shown that kid eating
diet can solve multiple health problems
oh it's so overblown and in fact what's
missing is the six seven studies that
suggest - get to the point big studies
hundreds of thousands of people these
are Association studies group of people
ate a certain way questionnaires food
questionnaires ones food questionnaires
several times they're in a number of
years follow these people up Harvard
School Public Health
Tufts school nutrition very prominent
places a dramatic rise in long-term
mortality by people's whose food pattern
it can be called the low-carb high-fat
diet a rise in death rate if you've had
a heart attack and you fill out
questionnaires at the Harvard School
Public Health and they follow you long
term and your diet can be described as a
low-carb high-fat diet you're much more
likely to die and follow-up than people
that describe diets that are closer to
high carb hopefully complex plant
choices though these aren't vegans you
know more like a Mediterranean style
diet so that's the untold story for
anybody listening and it's falling for
this optimization of performance and
metabolism and control of cardiovascular
risk the data needs to be addressed
about death rate and until there is a
study that resolves that issue and and
says that's wrong six seven different
studies in different parts of the world
I could not in any good conscious advise
somebody do a animal-based low-carb
ketogenic patter particularly with its
high in protein protein activates aging
pathways protein activates biochemical
pathways that right here in the city of
the Angels have been found from yeast to
mice to humans - cause accelerated aging
and aging in every aspect of our body
and it is animal protein rich in an
amino acid called leucine as the main
trigger and you can't get around at
grass-fed beef free-range chicken and
line-caught
fish all have tremendously more leucine
than the amino acid structure of plants
they have it but they don't have nearly
the same amount there might be a genetic
predisposition towards anxiety and and
whatever that Woodgate somebody a little
bit closer to pessimism but it's a
learned behavior and so anything that's
learned can be adjusted adopted so the
first is to know that there's options
and part of that process is to recognize
how many of the extraordinary doers in
the world think and they're more
optimistic than pessimistic just by my
experience if we're just taking an end
of one right now and then the the
challenge in this conversation is as
soon as people talk about optimism it
sounds like all the sudden we're gonna
get soft all of a sudden we're gonna get
you know let's hold hands and let's pick
some flowers together and everything's
gonna work out just right that's not
what optimism is an optimism I think
that optimism is at the center of mental
toughness to have the mental discipline
to be able to stay the course when the
[ __ ] is not going right hmm that's
that's the thing right there well it's
fortitude it takes a tremendous amount
of faith and composure to say I'm gonna
devote like this huge part of my life to
this goal whether it's professional or
athletic or whatever it is baked into
that has to be some sense that this is
going to lead you in a positive
direction right that things are gonna
work out maybe not exactly as you
imagined but that it'll deliver you to a
place that's better than wherever you
are at that moment that's exactly right
okay so then at some point how do you
chip in right how do you have really
trust yourself how do you trust that
whatever it is that you're going
whatever bet you're gonna play that it's
gonna work out and if it doesn't work
out you have the ability to figure it
out okay so we've got optimism we've got
locus of control and then we've also got
grit and those are three pillars in the
in the psychological framework that I
think are really important to pay
attention to so grit as you know from
Angela Duckworth passion perseverance
for long-term goals control the locus of
control like are you controlling what's
100 percent in your control are you
working towards that or caught up in the
noise of the other things that are
really important but you can't control
and getting those three cobble together
on a consistent basis that is that's a
nice significant piece of work to have
some durability
on the long play right in life one of
the things that you talk about a lot
that is just one of my favorite subjects
is this idea that we
come the stories that we tell about
ourselves those become predictors of
future behavior and outcomes and I would
imagine in the same way that you know on
the scale of optimism and pessimism that
that these stories are mutable I know
they're mutable but they're very
powerful right so in your kind of
inquiry earlier I was thinking about
some of the stories that I've
historically told myself and a lot of
them are around this idea that you know
I don't think I'm that talented but I
have this huge like work work ethic
capacity I know how to suffer I know I
actually like suffer I like you know I
have like it's all imagined you know and
it plays out as truth but I've been able
to make my way in the world be can
overcome whatever talent deficit gap
that I have because I'm willing to and
capable of out working the next guy and
so I've relied on that story to achieve
certain successes and then I credit that
story as fundamental to that success but
ultimately I see myself moving towards
burnout and these you know having to
confront these control issues in a way
that I'm now realizing it's it's not
only is it not sustainable like it's not
making me happy right and I and I have
this sense that I could be more
productive and I could be happier and
more fruitful if I let go of this
narrative and find a new one cool I mean
that's the that's like if we're swinging
from vines together and you've got
you've got a bead on how this vine is
getting created great momentum for you
and then you grab the next one it's not
quite as sturdy but you know you need to
let go of the one that's really strong
and it's got some good mums behind it
you know and it's got a good anchor and
lever on it to go to the new one that's
a little less sturdy but you think it's
going to take you in the right direction
like do you what if you fall you know
can you figure it out that and I'm not
looking at you that way I'm saying for
all of us so there is you know rational
emotive therapy is like take a look at
the worst case scenario feel that really
examine the worst
case scenario and oftentimes what
happens if you go within that kind of
dark place if you will and even write it
down so or talk about it with someone
that you really trust is that you end up
coming through going well the chances of
that happening are pretty low because
I'm pretty resourceful but if it did I'd
rather go for it than not go for it you
know so there's something in there that
ends up happening for people but the
thought that yes can they change a
thousand percent and you go back to the
constriction thoughts or the expansion
thoughts you know when you belly laugh
it's really good and like it just feels
really good that's space that's
expansion in there and so those thought
that lead to the freedom to have that
type of experience on a regular basis
wouldn't you trade a lot of that for
like I don't know whatever quote-unquote
successes you know outwardly success
isn't isn't that like really valuable
yeah and and and if we follow like
Harvard did that seventy five years
study on fulfillment and that's a long
study no seventy-five years right to
study fulfillment and what they found
two of them largest pillars for
fulfillment in life is grokking and
wrestling with the difficult questions
in life so not shying away from this is
a difficult question we're talking about
and I think we have and the other one is
deep relationships it's like Susan date
you know Susan David she's a she's a
Harvard psychologist who wrote this book
emotional agility I do I know address
yeah yeah but it's that idea like her
saying is what is it exactly I'm gonna
butcher it but like essentially
grappling with difficult emotions is the
price you pay for a meaningful life does
this success equate like the is being
fulfilled and and and and contented in
your life requires you to face these
things that you know kind of our culture
pushes up against and says don't worry
about that or take this pill or you know
just pretend it didn't happen and I
think what what's happening right now if
we kind of map less than a hundred years
like from the Industrial Revolution to
now is that our ancestry at some point
figured out that no machine's going to
take their job so they came home to the
dinner
table and they said you know what no
machines taking our that we're gonna
work we're gonna figure it not in this
house and so we've been we've been
handed down that work ethic ethos you
and I certainly have but many people
have been handed that down and then what
I think what it's turned into over time
as a generation of the has muted the
store are not muted but um shifted the
story just a little bit is that I need
to do extraordinary things to be
extraordinary
so the thought that I need to do more to
be more I think is wearing us out yeah
well I definitely bought into that yeah
and so at what you're not alone right
yeah but so there's a deep fatigue that
will come from that model in its time
for sure right now I think the timing of
it of this is eloquent that let's flip
the model that we need to be more and
let the doing flow from that place so
the be more be more what be more present
be more authentic be here more often be
more gracious right be more and then
whatever the doing that we want to
experience in life
imagine the output difference one is you
get those moments and joy you increase
maybe the frequency of them and then
what would happen to the doing if they
came from your pure a more pure place
right
that's unchartered territory for me mmm
I've always been the guy who who you
know it's a you know my operating system
is if I didn't if I didn't like really
suffer to create whatever I'm creating
then I didn't work hard enough at it you
know there's more I can I can I can
extract more blood from that stone just
a couple more all-nighters and I can
make it you know point zero zero zero
one percent better you know and it's not
working well it works it's just not it's
not a it's not a sustainable fuel source
right and they're you know we're not
we're not fragile
humans are not fragile we can do
extraordinary things to this frame of
ours and but we do need to refuel yeah
and so you know how long can you go
without sleep you can do it for a little
bit but not too long how long can you go
without water not that long you know
food you know
so we can do extraordinary things to our
body that are debilitating are our
resources but that's not that's not that
that's not the big goal right so then
what are the big movers for you like
what is it that you want to do in life
that's driving you into you know I don't
know fatigue I mean I think that that
fundamentally it's it's trying to find
ways to provide the most help that I can
to the most people in the most
substantive way the most meaningful way
that's what gets me excited that's what
gets me out of bed in the morning like I
love the training and all their the race
whatever I did all those but that doing
all of that you know in some bizarre you
know alchemy of the galaxy has put me in
this place now where now I can be a
resource for other people and trying to
to be the best at that that I can
possibly be is what I'm focused on I
love the thought you know walk the talk
you know like talk about it but walk
about it and you're talking about how
you want to walk about it you know you
want to live that way whatever that way
is for you that's like sturdy and nimble
all in the same you know way and I feel
it at the same time like so much of your
work is about presence you know how can
you be more in the moment how can you
create that space and and that you know
these conversations are coming up more
and more in my life and they're
transpiring in a cultural moment in
which we've never been more distracted
and the demands on our attention have
never been greater like you know with
these things in our pocket it's like
there's no space
there's no anytime you're waiting in a
line you can easily you know find
something to do your phone and and so
you have to exercise a lot more
diligence around creating that space
what we're outmatched
you know like technology companies that
are really on it have tens to hundreds
of PhDs that really understand the
neurology of behavior the thinking
patterns of we're outmatched yeah you
know this guy Tristan Harris sure you
yeah I'm just doing a lot of work around
them that's right we're completely
outmatched and you know he's on it he's
early in the days of it and he's going
to take on some tech giants around it
and but I will say that let's say I'm
bullish on technology I think that like
yes we need to move in that direction
but knowing that there's a
counterbalance so I feel the same things
that you do like the draw to the
dopamine hit I check in my phone by
trying to catch up with the onslaught of
emails that come through and yes yes yes
at the same time what I feel is
irresponsible to not carve out enough
time to train deep focus because that's
like a multitask thin slicing you know
rip-and-run type of experience so then
the counter balance needs to be spaced
to be able to condition my mind to be
more present to be more aware of what's
actually happening in the internal
ecosystem and you know I'll tell you
what for me at least there's a razor's
edge to it it's frickin hard to be
truthful and honest and the
vulnerability even when nobody else is
around to be vulnerable with oneself is
hard and so I turn aliy I've been
fascinated by the razor's edge that was
my early fascination about sport so
working in hostile and rugged and
extreme environments if you will and
what I've also come to value is that
some of the most intense environments
are the ones that we have within just
ourselves sitting at home alone there's
nobody nobody at home you could do
whatever you want what are you gonna do
it's the ultimate battle ground right
but like when you create enough space to
listen to that inner experience that
inner dialogue that in turn air ative
whatever you want to call it which is
you know it's it's a human experience
you'll learn some stuff about yourself
you don't want to be reminded of you
don't want to remember that you're a
coward that you're dishonest that you're
afraid that you're gonna be exposed and
I'm checking the list for things that I
don't want to say about me and I'd like
to play the game that those are not me
those are for other people that's me to
now and it's hard because you know what
we want we want to be Noble we want to
be courageous we want to be caring we
want to be great
as a human as a doer and a beer and you
know you can't get there without some
real discerning honesty you know people
say Oh Americans been totally less fat
you know we're fatter than ever
low fat is dead it's all sugar but we
may have been told eat less fat but I
went to the US Department of Agriculture
database because they keep track of the
entire food supply not what people say
they're eating but what they're actually
eating and oftentimes there's a big
discrepancy and what we found is that in
every decade since 1950 we may have been
told eat less fat we're eating a lot
more fat 67% more fat more sugar more
meat and more calories more of
everything more of everything so not
surprising we're fat not because reading
to a little fat but because weird eating
too much of everything yes so the idea
is that that it's not that the low-fat
thing didn't work it's that people
didn't actually do it and the other
thing is besides getting more fat is
people when they did replace fat they
ruin replace it with sugar so you have a
snack well cookies and you know the
Entenmann's cakes and things like that
and that's not a good choice right but I
think if you actually look at all of the
data there's more evidence than ever
that an optimal diet is low in fat and
low in sugar it's predominantly fruits
vegetables whole grains legumes soy
products in their natural forms and
we've been doing studies for 40 years so
you know having been in all these
different diet Wars and I debates I said
you know look I'm done you know we we've
done every study that we've done has
shown that these same lifestyle changes
can reverse heart disease we're able to
show that for the first time type-2
diabetes high blood pressure high
cholesterol obesity we're doing another
first randomized trial now to see if we
can actually reverse Alzheimer's disease
we found that when you change your
lifestyle it changes your genes you know
hundreds of genes over 500 genes in
three months turning on the good genes
turning off the bad genes in just three
months we found that in a study we did
that we published that with craig Venter
who first decoded the human genome right
we did a study with Elizabeth Blackburn
it got the Nobel Prize for discovering
telomeres the ends of our chromosomes
that regulate how long with it we've
showed for the first time that in just
three months we can increase telomerase
the enzyme that repairs and lengthens
telomeres by 30% and over a five year
period we show it again for the first
time we can actually lengthen telomeres
in a sense reversing aging at a cellular
level so the more diseases we study and
the more underlying mechanisms we look
at
the more reasons we have to explain why
these simple changes are so powerful and
how quickly people can get better what
do you think that the challenges are are
that you face in trying to communicate
this message because if you canvass the
conversations that are occurring right
now they do tend to swirl around this
you know new obsession with eating a
high-fat diet and you know everything
you ever heard about saturated fat is
wrong and people are you know all about
keto and you know it's always there's
always a new thing coming right a new
craze a new trend this is something
you've you've been immersed in this for
forty years at this point and your
message really hasn't changed from the
studies that you did so long ago to date
I mean they just sort of continue to
confirm yes what you've been saying all
along well it may seem do but it's not
new I mean I've been hearing this for 40
years it actually goes back to the 1800s
it's really just it's an Atkins diet
redux whether it's an Atkins diet a
paleo diet a ketogenic diet it's all the
same thing and it tell first of all
telling people what I want to hear is
always a good way to sell books or
magazines or newspapers or whatever and
as all there's those media have been so
disrupted they're always looking for you
know the next thing that they can hook
readers with number two is that the
studies are showing quite clearly that
yeah you can lose weight on these diets
because most people do eat too many
refined carbs and so eating fewer
refined carbs you're gonna lose weight
and Atkins and I agreed on that it's
what you replace them with you know I'd
love to be able to tell people that you
know steak and burgers and so on are
good for you but they're not you know
and if you actually look at the the idea
is to lose weight in ways that enhance
your health rather than mortgage it and
there was a study in the New England
Journal of Medicine that Stephen Smith
published a few years ago that showed
actually pictures and what happens on
different diets what happens in your
arteries um you can lose weight with
chemotherapy or smoking cigarettes or
lots of ways of losing weight that
aren't really good for you amphetamines
are a good way of losing weight and what
they found is that on a Whole Foods
plant-based diet your arteries are clean
on a typical standard American diet
which has the great acronym of sad
they're partially caught in a high
hi animal protein diet whether you call
it an Atkins or keto or paleo diet
they're severely clogged and even if
their weight and even if their blood
pressure may be lower because these
often work through what are called non
traditional risk factors things that
people you know they're little white
blood cells that nibble in your arteries
and keep them clean and so on and it's
not even just about over long periods of
time even a single meal this high in fat
cholesterol can reduce blood flow to
your brain can reduce blood flow to your
heart there's you know the movie that
James Cameron and let me say hi us and
others said game changers will be coming
back soon has this great scene with
three athletes and they give them a
plant-based meal and they measure how
the the frequency and the hardness of
their erections at night right and then
they give them a meat based meal on the
next night and found the same and did
the same thing and they found they had
three to five hundred percent more
frequent erections on a plant-based meal
than a meat based meal and ten to
fifteen percent harder erections in fact
the told the film career became vegan
after that will definitely get guys
attention right it takes it away from
this fear-based approach like oh I can't
do what I want you know am I gonna live
longer they're just gonna seem longer
all those kind of cliches to say oh
these things are so much more dynamic
than we once realized that when you eat
this way your brain gets more blood flow
you can actually grow so many brain
neurons in just a few weeks your brain
gets bigger particularly those parts
your brain like the hippocampus the
control memory that you want to get
bigger you know when people get old if I
said like you know what was where I
leave my keys and what was that person's
name a lot of that's reversible your
skin gets more blood so you don't age as
quickly your heart gets more blood we
found you can reverse heart disease or
sexual organs get more blood flow and
when people realize that it's not just
about living longer it's about feeling
better and improving the quality of life
it really reframes that debate from you
know fear of dying which is not
sustainable to joy of living and feeling
good and pleasure which really are right
there seems to be a lot of confusion out
there right now about saturated fat and
cholesterol for years the consensus the
scientific nutrition consensus was that
saturated fat was bad high LDL is bad
and then suddenly some studies came out
that caught the attention of the media
and there were a lot of headlines and a
lot of articles written about this idea
that everything you ever heard about
saturated fat is wrong
cholesterol is something that we need
and it's good and you shouldn't worry
about saturated fat that actually
saturated fat is a health food so again
walk me through how we got to this point
and perhaps you know clarify the record
or share your perspective on yes I
remember I was in Davos at the World
Economic Forum two and a half years ago
when Time magazine put a stick of butter
on their gutters back yeah and Nancy
Gibbs was the editor-in-chief at the
time and she was doing this one-on-one
interview with me and she said so what'd
you think of our cover and I said well
not not not so well and she said well
why not I said well cause it's not true
you know the studies were showing that
saturated fat doubles your risk of
Alzheimer's disease for everyone one pad
of butter your risk of premature death
from all causes we look at 300,000
people in the Harvard physicians in
Harvard Nurses Health Study goes up by
5% so these things really are important
now cholesterol is good in the sense
that your body needs cholesterol it's a
building block for you know sex hormones
and nerve coverings and all kinds of
things and because precisely because
it's so important your body will make
all the cholesterol it needs the dietary
requirement for cholesterol is is zero
but getting all this extra cholesterol
you know there's we found in our studies
that there was a dose-response
relationship between the intake of
dietary cholesterol and dietary fat and
changes in the blockages in the arteries
this was also found in what was called
the the class study the David
Blankenhorn did at USC many years ago is
one of the first studies to show that
the drugs could actually reverse
cholesterol lowering drugs could reverse
heart disease and he found that the same
dose-response relationship the more fat
you consumed including saturated fat and
especially saturated fat the more
clogged your arteries become and even a
single meal as we've been talking about
it makes a difference so you know I'd
love to be able to tell people that fat
is good that it's all sugar but it's not
an optimal diet is low in both now the
third aspect is is animal protein you
know which people in this whole
versus carbons debate I want to make
sure that we cover animal protein
because there's more and more evidence
coming out showing that animal protein
is inflammatory it causes chronic
inflammation it causes oxidative stress
and independent of its effect on you
know the fat versus carbs one study came
out that showed that people who ate a
lot of animal protein had a 75%
increased risk of premature death from
all causes and a 400 to 500 percent
type 2 diabetes and prostate breast and
colon cancer so you know again people
like to simplify things and flecked like
it's all one thing it's not one thing
it's all these diet but it's all these
other lifestyle factors as well
[Music]